[Music]
wait let them think they have the higher
ground
fire send in Infantry take their
position on the higher
ground
[Applause]
covery from the West Pi's their
flankes ni ground uncover the
[Music]
cannon what now sir we
in off the ice
withdraw cut off their
Retreat General we are
discovered good
wait ni it's a CL
retre I'm not built like other
[Music]
men move along now those in power only
see me as a Gro unfit for higher
office just like witches at black m but
I follow in the footsteps of Alexander
the Great and
Caesar evil minds PL destruction if you
look down you'll see a
surprise once you see it you will always
want it sorcer of death
construction I must warn you I won't
will not leave a second of
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it at top my own
[Music]
head
where you want to be great but you are
nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
will all safe again without This
Vermin whose country are we
in
mine
[Music]